we talked the other night when we talked
about cockneys vs zombies about your
playlist what you were listening to I
know that's important part of your
writing process what were you listening
to you when you were writing tower block
look it was a lot of really sort of grim
serious heavy stuff but a bit of pink
floyd some there's a couple of songs off
the new peter gabriel album of covers
which are really quite sort of grim and
dark a couple of pj harvey songs just
some real sort of heavy grim moody
depressing stuff to get you in the right
frame of mind absolutely yeah I did any
of those influence the soundtrack of the
film well there was one couple songs
everyone loved but they were very very
expensive there was one song I had in
the playlist it was a portishead song
and I didn't tell anyone this but when
they were doing the first rough assembly
they cut one of the first scenes and
they put they used that song as a temp
track so we were clearly all on the same
page musically so and I think I think
the music and the finished movie is very
sort of reminiscent of the kind of mood
we all wanted it to be so you're talking
about the movie you wanted it to be as a
very different vibe isn't it of course
from companies vs zombies what was the
inspiration for this one this was just
it was just an idea that came to me out
i was watching another movie at fright
fest a few years ago i thought the
killer was going to do something in the
climax joe and Sykes or spoil both films
and he didn't do it and I thought that
would actually be quite a horrible thing
to happen in our movie I thought wait
why can't I be the beginning instead of
the end and then just stick them in that
for 90 minutes to see how they get out
if they can get out so I just going to
just kind of ran with that really
thought this could be a really nasty
shocking scary tense ride I know that
you've got kind of a little bit of a
theme emerging haven't you with the BBFC
the British Board of Film classification
your films so far been strong bloody
violence and strong language how do you
feel about several blood ease and
several Gauri's I'm really excited
because I I mean a lot of the time when
I was a teenager oh and I would go to
the video shop to rent VHS in the
forties I would look at the back of the
box and I'd read the description and
look at the pictures and then I would
look at the BBFC thing and see what it
said and if it said like you know
contains extremely distressing
disturbing images of violence and
thought then absolves I will get that so
I'm very very happy
they do you think that's how people are
still judging films today maybe I know
it is because I several friends do the
same if they're going to see a new
horror film and they look at the
description it says contains miles peril
and there we go is that it I want more
than that I want to be utterly terrified
yes and I say this as someone who has
got something like that my first short
cheap break gravity the description was
mild fantasy peril so I thought that was
actually quite cool so I've got that on
a t-shirt and nobody talked the other
night about cockneys vs zombies you had
a whole four-point plan about how you'd
outlive the zombie outbreak do you have
a plan for a tower block scenario she
not actually don't and that's probably
why this movie is quite sort of grim and
bleak because it just things like that
really terrified even though it's not
likely to happen but things like that
really terrify me sort of real world
things where I just don't know how our
deal with it I was saying somebody else
that all my characters a little part of
me so the brave ones or how I like to
think I would be if I was being brave
the Cowardly ones are how I would
probably be if I was being cowardly so
you know I'd like to think that I would
going to step up and try and deal with
it but I've probably just be in the
corner of crying wetting myself and
you're a co-producer on this film aren't
you tablet what did that mean it meant
that I got to got to be on well I'm
normally on set as much as I like but
you know it definitely meant a got to be
on set as much as I like
I got sort of joint approval on lots of
the elements but after the first few
days everything was going pretty much
exactly where I wanted it to so you know
there weren't really any arguments at
all want to ask what you are working on
next I know this subject called Silent
Night of the Living Dead is enough
that's another zombie horror comedy
that's more like gremlins meets full she
kind of approach it zombies at Christmas
in a small town a few other horror
movies thriller and one sci-fi and an
action film so we'll see what gets made
first and then he cashed in mind for any
of them I'd love to do something with
michelle ryan again i'd love to like do
a prior full-on actually we were just
her as the lead all of the people I've
worked with before I would like to work
with him again I kill to have Kurt
Russell in something of mine because
he's just a hero of mine
you